(gentle music)
- Greetings, everybody. Happy Tuesday.
We are now making the transition
into the 19th and the 20th centuries.
By the end of this lecture,
we should be in 1918, 1919, 1920.
The the premise of this lecture
is that we are talking about
revolutions and republics.
The tricky thing about
the revolution of 1917,
the Bolshevik Revolution,
like all revolutions,
is that it pretends to start new.
And in some way, revolutions do start new.
Old elites are overthrown,
violence is applied,
regimes are changed, and so on.
But nevertheless, there
is a weighty inheritance,
which will have to be dealt
with in one way or another.
And so before we get to the revolution,
we are going to make sure
that we have the 19th century down.
I'm gonna spend some time
on the 19th century first.
Something similar could
be said about republics,
perhaps in a minor key.
The republics that are founded in 1918
are founded as new states,
as states that have broken completely
with their imperial past.
So the most important
republic for us is going to be
the Polish Republic,
which we'll be talking
about also on Thursday.
But are also two attempts
to start Ukrainian states,
there's a West Ukrainian
National Republic,
and a Ukrainian National Republic.
And Republics, as new state forums
also a bit have this idea that
we've broken with the past,
we've started something new.
And naturally, as people studying history,
we're going to be a little
bit suspicious of this
when we try to understand, for example,
why the two Ukrainian attempts
at founding republics failed
it will help to know
about the history, right?
So, if we just talk about
the principle of the matter,
there's no reason why the
Ukrainians wouldn't have had
a republic when, say
the Czechoslovaks did.
If we were just going to talk about
measuring the political
devotion of people in 1918,
many more people died for
Ukrainian independence in 1918,
then died for Czechoslovak independence.
That can't be the explanation either,
we're gonna need some
other sort of explanation.
And whatever explanation it's going to be
history is going to help.
It is true of course, that,
and I'm sure you'll be
sad to see their passing,
the empires we've been
studying do come to an end.
They are going to come to an end.
We're gonna bring them to
an end in this lecture.
The Habsburg monarchy, which has existed
in some form or another
for more than 500 years,
will come to an end in November of 1918.
The state based in Muscovy,
which in some form or another,
has existed since the 15th century,
and as the Russian Empire
has existed since 1721
will come to an end in 1917.
Those two state forms will come to an end
and they'll be attempts at a fresh start.
But our thesis here is,
there really isn't such
thing as a fresh start.
So, I wanna try to begin
by making really clear
a point that I was making last time
about the significance of the division
of Ukrainian territory.
It would be really, really
easy if we could teach classes,
and you can kind of see,
like in history textbooks
sort of dream of this too,
where there was one territory
and there was one state,
and there was one people, right?
Of course, if I say that,
it sounds rather fascist and it should,
but it would be really simple
if there were just one territory
and the boundaries never changed,
and there was one people there
and there was a state the whole time.
That's never how it's
been for any country.
And we've been trying to explore the idea
that the divisions in
what will later become
the national territory
are not just a problem,
but also a source of friction,
sometimes creative friction.
That the differences between
different parts of a territory,
depending upon what empire it belongs to,
matter not just as differences,
but sometimes as constructive components
of what will later become
a national society.
And so to follow this,
to make this argument,
we have to be really sure about
which parts of the country
belong to which territories.
We are now in the 19th and 20th centuries
moving for the first time into the moment
where what matters is
the east-west division.
Where there is, you could reasonably say,
there's something called Western Ukraine
centered in Galicia,
which has a different experience
than the rest of Ukraine,
which is in the Russian Empire.
So, to review, you'll know that this is,
I know it's so hard,
like I still struggle with
this and it's been 30 years,
but the left bank, the left
bank is the eastern part,
and the right bank is
the western part, right?
Because you have to look at it
from the point of view of the river.
And if you look at it, and
the river's flowing south.
So if you can, you know,
I was about to make a drug joke,
but I didn't because the camera's on,
but you can laugh anyway, thank you.
(student laughing)
I appreciate that.
So you just look at it from
the point of view of the river.
The left bank, the eastern
part comes under Russian rule
in the late 17th century, along with Kyiv.
The right bank, right, the western half
comes under Russian rule
a hundred years later.
So it's all under Russian rule,
but there's a meaningful difference
of a hundred years there.
And then of course, there's
the third little part
with Galicia, which never comes
under Russian rule at all,
but which falls under the Habsburgs.
So I wanna pause and say a bit more
about some themes in the
history of Ukrainian territory
under Russia,
because all we managed
to really do last time
was to get the territory
straight, which is already a lot.
But there are a couple
of important themes here,
which I wanna make sure we get through.
Having to do with social
history first of all.
In 1861, serfdom is brought to an end.
Russia has lost this war in Crimea,
a period of great reforms follows.
The most important of these great reforms
is the abolition of serfdom.
So the vast majority of the population
is no longer compelled
to work for the people
on whose land they live.
There is a problem with the end of serfdom
which you can probably anticipate,
if you've ever thought at
all about how, you know,
capitalism works, it's
kind of a familiar problem.
People are freed from
their personal bondage
to local landowners,
but they're not given enough
land themselves to survive,
right? Or to do well in general.
So you have people who are,
and so this raises this perpetual question
about liberalism, right?
Like, is negative freedom enough?
If I say, "You don't have
to do anything for me,
but I own all the land," what's
our relationship gonna be?
Well, you are, on Monday, you are freed,
you got negative freedom,
but on Tuesday you have
to come to me and like,
take my conditions for
working my land, right?
So I'm simplifying a bit,
but that's the problem
at the end of Serfdom.
People are personally
free, but how well they do
and de facto how free
they're going to become
and what their political
attitudes might be,
will depend on how much land they get.
So from 1861 forward this land question
is gonna be a major theme
until industrialization,
which is second half of the 20th century
for most of this region, land
reform is a major question.
In Ukraine in general,
peasants got very small land allotments,
smaller than the rest of the country,
at a time of growing population.
So there was a lot of
social economic pressure
on the bulk of the population,
which is in the countryside.
And most of the population,
this is an important point,
stays in the countryside.
So there's a stereotype
that the Ukrainians
are in the countryside,
and that stereotype is generally true.
And there's a reason for it, which is that
because the land is so fertile,
it makes sense for me, I'll go
back to being the landowner,
it makes sense for me
to keep you on that land
working for me to export
that grain if I can,
because I can make a
profit that way, right?
And that means that when when
industrialization takes place
in what's now southeastern Ukraine,
in the familiar part of Ukraine
which we call the Donbas,
you probably heard of the Donbas right?
It just means the Donetsk basin.
Like a lot of these like
apparently tricky, you know,
Russian conglomerations, it
just means Donetsk basin, right?
So you can like impress your friends
with that bit of of knowledge.
So, when the Donbas industrializes,
beginning of the 1870s,
most of the peasants
who come to work there
are actually not Ukrainian.
Most of the peasants
who come to work there
will be coming from Russia,
where the land is less fruitful,
where the landlords have
less of an incentive
to keep people on the land.
And this is at the beginning
of a very important
social and economic change in Ukraine,
which is industrialization
and urbanization.
There's coal in the
Donbas, there still is,
in the 1870s, 1880s, this becomes a source
of most of the coal, about 70% of the coal
for the entire Russian Empire.
In a familiar pattern, the coal is mined
under the auspices of foreign companies,
usually British or French,
although one of the most
famous of the industrialists
of the Donbas was a
man called John Hughes,
who was Welsh.
And he got a city named after
him, which is sort of cool,
Iuzivka, right?
Which sounds like sounds
like a sort of deeply,
Iuzivka, right?
Like what could be more
Ukrainian than Iuzivka,
is named after John Hughes.
That city was later renamed Donetsk,
and then later renamed Stalino
and then later renamed Donetsk.
And it's currently a few miles
behind the lines in this war.
Another city which grows from nothing
during the period of industrialization
is called Kryvyi Rih, which, you know,
just means kind of twisted corner.
It's a beautiful name, right?
Kryvyi Rih is where Zelens'kyi was born,
if that helps you at all.
It's in south central Ukraine.
And it was the, when
the railroad was built
from the Donbas to Kryvyi Rih,
then Kryvyi Rih is where
the iron was spelted.
So this gives you an idea
of what this industrialization was like.
It was nationally or
ethnically a bit strange
because it was largely
not the Ukrainian peasants
who were working there, but
largely Russian peasants.
And also it was constrained
by internal tariffs.
So the Ukrainian part
of the Russian empire
was producing coal and
it was producing iron,
but it wasn't producing finished products.
The finished products were sold back
into this part of the Russian Empire
at higher prices, right?
So this is a kind of classical form
of colonial exploitation.
There were internal tariffs
inside the Russian Empire,
also applied to Poland, by the way.
Okay? So this industrialization
combined with Catherine
the Great's project
of a new Russia earlier on,
means that there are
essentially new cities
in what's now Ukraine.
Iuzivka, which becomes Donetsk, new city.
There's another city called Katerinaslav,
which of course is after
Catherine the Great.
Katerinaslav is later
called Dnipropetrovsk
and it's now called Dnipro.
And it's also also a major
industrial city of the southeast.
So you have these, and
Odessa, which is again,
that's Catherine's, you know,
delight for these Greek sounding things.
So Odessa is the, you know,
the major port in Ukraine now,
Odessa is a new city, Iuzivka new city,
Katerinaslav new cities,
and during the 19th century,
Kyiv and Kharkiv, which
are very old cities,
are culturally Russified.
They move in the opposite
direction of cities like Prague,
which is very interesting.
In the same decades where Prague,
the main city in the Czech lands,
moves from being German
speaking to Czech speaking,
that is, it takes on the
language of the countryside,
in Kyiv it's the opposite.
In Kharkiv, it's the opposite.
In both of those cities in the
middle of the 19th century,
most people probably still spoke Ukrainian
and the second most important
language was probably Polish
by the end of the 19th century
the most important
language in these cities
is going to be Russia.
So as these cities grow,
they become more culturally Russian.
And the new cities in the southeast
also are largely Russian speaking. Okay?
So that introduces you to an issue
which you can see is still present
more than a hundred years later.
Notice that in all of that,
I am talking about the eastern
part of Ukraine, right?
The right bank.
In the left bank matters
are a bit different.
There isn't much urbanization over there.
Yeah, I know, it's hard, pause.
I don't know what to do. It's tricky.
The western part, right?
I may have even reversed it, sorry.
But the western part, right?
The right bank is a different story.
There the Polish landlords
still own most of the land.
There the key crops are things like beets.
This is before sugar is being exported
from the Caribbean all
over the world and so on.
So beets are raised to make sugar
and this is a world center of that.
The old land structure, in other words,
is largely preserved in the right bank,
in the western part,
with the Polish landlords
pretty much all the way through.
With severe land hunger and all the rest.
After 1861, the next
important turning point
in the Russian Empire is
the revolution of 1905,
which we can't skip over.
So there's a pattern here,
it's a pretty important
historical pattern,
if you want to have your
country reform, lose a war.
It's kind of a difficult plan,
like it's a difficult plan to follow
because you rarely say,
"Let's go out and lose a war."
But if you wanna lose
a war there's a trick,
which is start one.
That's like, that'll
usually get you there.
No, I mean, well, okay,
at least half the time
it'll get you there.
So this may sound slightly
familiar, in 1904,
I have to shorten this a lot, but in 1904,
the Russian Empire was sure
that it would defeat Japan
because Japan was an Asian country,
obviously inferior from the
point of view of the Russians.
So they sent their fleet
all the way around Africa,
all the way over to Asia
in order to be sunk by
the Japanese right away.
And they didn't do much better on land,
they lost the war with
Japan, which set off,
and the war itself set off protests.
So when people talk about
how this war is a risky business for Putin
this is what they often have in mind,
that Russia lost the
Crimean War and reformed,
that Russia lost the war with Japan,
and then was forced to reform,
that Russia was about to collapse
under the weight of the First World War
and that led to revolution, right?
So when people say like this,
like the Russian state
historically has been,
has faced pressure during war time,
these are the examples they have in mind.
The Japanese example's very important.
So under the pressure of this defeat
the Russian state forms a parliament,
which lasts for a couple of years.
The restrictions on Ukrainian newspapers
and publishing houses are released,
there are student strikes
by Ukrainian students
which lead to the introduction,
over the short term at least,
of Ukrainian subjects in
universities at Kharkiv
and then Odessa. Okay?
So that's the Russian Empire.
Many, many, many more
Ukrainians than in Galicia.
Much, much more territory.
The specific forms of Russian
rule, mostly peasant country,
and I should have said this before,
almost completely illiterate,
which is very important for
national self consciousness.
It's very hard to do national politics
without the written word, right?
You can have the printing press,
you can have the political
parties and so on,
not that Russia had the political parties,
but you can have all the apparatus,
but you also need literacy.
In the Habsburg monarchy
you have much greater rates of literacy
than the Russian Empire. Okay?
So, now let's do the Habsburgs,
again, very, very quickly.
Circa 1700, the Habsburg's
shift from being a world power
to being a European power.
And the key turning points here are 1526,
which is unbelievably complicated,
I probably rushed through
it a little bit last time.
There's a marriage compact,
it's made by this guy,
Wladyslaw Jagiellonczyk, his son,
who was going to inherit the crowns,
instead dies under his horse
at the Battle of Mohacs in 1526,
which allows the son's
brother-in-law, a Habsburg,
to lay claim to Hungary
and Croatia and so on.
That claim is eventually realized by 1699,
the Habsburgs then become a European power
just at the moment when they
cease to be a world power.
They're enabled in that
by the Poles in 1683,
who save Vienna from the Ottomans.
Less than a century later,
1772, the Habsburgs nevertheless
take part in the first
partition of Poland,
which gets them this territory of Galicia.
Which is important for us
because Galicia, the Poles call,
okay, this is like even the TAs
are allowed to answer this one,
what do the Poles refer?
How do you refer to
that territory in Polish
in the 18th century?
I'm raising the stakes.
It's like, now there's somebody out there
who's like watching this on YouTube
who's tortured because they know
and they're like in their living room,
raising their hand at the
screen. Ruthenia, right?
Rus, the Poles said Rus,
they said Czerwona Rus,
they called this Red Ruthenia, right?
So that word Rus is also in Polish,
century, century, centuries
later to designate,
designate Eastern Orthodox territories.
Galicia is the Habsburg
term for these territories.
Okay, so the Habsburgs control Galicia,
they also control a territory
I didn't mention before,
a smaller territory called Bukovina.
Bukovina is a mixed at this
time, Ukrainian speaking,
Yiddish speaking, Romanian
speaking territory.
If you've ever, I'm gonna
try to make this familiar
the best I can.
If you've ever heard of
the poet, Paul Celan,
who wrote the most famous
poem about the Holocaust
which is called is called
"Todesfuge", death fugue,
Celan was from Czernowitz, or Chernivtsi,
which is the main city in Bukovina.
Bukovina is like the,
it's now like the south,
the southern part of western Ukraine,
a little bit of the southern
part of western Ukraine.
The point is that Bukovina, like Galicia
was also under the
Habsburgs, also like Galicia,
there were politicians,
there were parliamentarians,
the language was allowed to be used.
There were newspapers.
All of these things that
I said about Galicia
also apply in lesser measure to Bukovina.
Now, another thing which I
didn't talk about though enough,
I made this argument,
which I hope we all got,
about how secular politics
flourishes in Galicia,
in part because the moment
when the Russian Empire
is most repressive towards
the Ukrainian language,
remember Valuev, Ems, 1863,
1876, is during that moment,
the Habsburg monarchy is
opening up new basic law,
quasi constitution 1867.
And so at that moment, these
very intelligent politically,
very sophisticated political intellectuals
move from the Russian Empire to Galicia
and stay there for the next
several decades, right?
But that's all about secular politics
and secular politics
is not the only story.
There's also a very
important story in Galicia,
which has to do with religion
and with another east
west division, right?
East west divisions are
like, that's new, right?
19th century, 20th century.
There's an east west division now
in Eastern Christianity, okay?
So Eastern Christianity, right?
You remember Byzantium,
it's Byzantium that converts Kyiv.
Kyiv is the historical center
of Eastern Christianity
in the world.
It is where the Metropolitanate,
the Metropolitan sat
for hundreds of years.
It was also where orthodox
theology and orthodox thinking,
along with, along with Chernihiv,
Kyiv is the place where orthodox thinking,
orthodox theology, orthodox
disputes became very impressive,
especially in the 17th century.
And interestingly, this is just,
I mean a fascinating thing,
which is in the dissertation
of a Yale PhD, actually,
Levgeniia Sakal, I don't
have her name on the sheet,
but her name is Geniia Sakal.
But in her PhD she shows
how a lot of the ways
that the Russian church
now identifies itself
emerged in the need to carry
out disputes with Kyiv.
So in the late 17th century,
I mentioned this earlier,
in the late 17th century
Kyiv and Chernihiv
are suddenly within Russia
and in Moscow they have orthodoxy,
but they don't have theology, right?
They don't have dispute, they
don't have that tradition.
Whereas in Kyiv, they have a lot of it
because of reformation,
counter reformation,
renaissance, having to
deal with the Poles,
having to deal with all of Europe,
having to deal with all of this mess.
All possible variations of Protestantism,
the counter reformation, having
to deal with the Jesuits.
I mean, probably some of
you went the Jesuit schools,
but having to deal with the
Jesuits always, you know,
tends to sharpen the mind, right?
So, I'm gonna get an email about that.
(students laughing)
So, but the point is that all of these,
all of this necessity of
disputation over the generations
meant that Kyiv was a
center of religious dispute
whereas Moscow was not.
In Moscow, they learned to
argue about religion from Kyiv
and they came up with the
arguments which now characterize
what they say about the Russian church,
namely that the Russian church
is a kind of pure continuation
of Byzantine traditions,
blah, blah, blah.
Which is not true at all.
It's simply not true.
But it's a kind of cool position to take,
like we are the pure,
unadulterated version
of the way Christianity
was supposed to be.
We got it directly from
Byzantium a thousand years ago
with this baptism and so on.
That argument, they made up
as they were disputing with Kyiv.
And in order to make that argument,
they of course borrowed all
kinds of arguments from Kyiv
and from Europe, and
they learned languages.
In other words, they became
very sophisticated European,
you know, theologians in
order to make this argument
that they weren't sophisticated
European theologians.
So, okay, but that's, anyway, it's really,
it's an interesting thing about
the Russian church, right?
And all of these stories
about how we are pure,
and we've been the same
way forever, right?
Those stories usually emerge
in contact with someone else.
In fact, they always do,
interestingly enough, Okay?
So, but so the point here is that
we also have an east west
division now in Christianity
because the Metropolitanate in Kyiv,
the center of Eastern Orthodoxy in Kyiv
is gonna be liquidated in 1721.
Kyiv becomes, in a very complicated story,
subordinate to Moscow.
Moscow takes on the role,
which you're probably familiar with
as the center of Eastern Orthodoxy.
But meanwhile, there's another church,
another eastern right
church, which exists,
but effectively only in
the Habsburg monarchy.
And that's the church which
is called Greek Catholic,
or Uniate, U-N-I-A-T-E.
It was formed in 1596
by the Union of Brest
as an attempt to bring all of eastern
and western Christianity together.
It failed to do that,
but it succeeded in
creating a third church.
So, the people who
stayed with this project
were called Uniates and they were and are
characterized by an Eastern rite,
you know, so icons and song, right?
Whereas, but they were
subordinate to the Pope in Rome.
They're part of the
Catholic Church, right?
The Catholic Church is not the same thing
as the Roman Catholic Church.
Roman Catholics may be
many of the Catholics,
but technically Roman
Catholicism is only one way
to be Catholic and there are
many other ways to be Catholic.
And so the Greek Catholic Church
is inherited by the Habsburgs.
They actually rename it Greek
Catholic, it's called Uniate.
They rename it Greek Catholic.
They create an academy in Vienna
to educate these Greek Catholic
priests. Very important.
And then for decades,
they use the Greek Catholic priests
as the kind of informal messengers
of small e enlightenment
in the Galatian countryside.
Spreading literacy,
spreading general knowledge,
spreading knowledge about politics, right?
And so that makes the
Habsburgs very different.
And it creates a tradition which becomes
a kind of Ukrainian tradition,
especially thanks to the work of one man
whose name was Andrei Sheptyts'kyi.
Andrei Sheptyts'kyi was a
fantastically interesting fellow
from a Polish aristocratic family
who converted to both Greek Catholicism,
technically not a conversion,
shifted to Greek Catholicism,
converted to being Polish,
okay also not technically a conversion
but became Polish, right?
Went from being a Polish
aristocrat, Roman Catholic
to being a Ukrainian
churchman man of the people
with great success.
It's a long story, I wish
I had more time for it.
But one of the things
that he succeeded in doing
was connecting the idea of
the people with the church.
And the people as a kind of national idea
with the the Greek Catholic Church. Okay.
Watch this segue.
At the beginning of the First World War,
he was abducted by the Russians. Okay?
It's about, that's as good as
my segue is gonna get here.
So he's, so you have to
imagine Sheptyts'kyi,
so you already have in your mind, right,
that there are these secular
Ukrainian politicians
who are operating the 1880s, 1890s.
And you have to think alongside that
there's also this Greek Catholic church,
which is headed by this man Sheptyts'kyi,
which is becoming more
Ukrainian by the year.
That's important too.
Both the secular part
and the religious part
of the national movement
in Galicia are important.
And they're both different as you see,
significantly from what's
happening in the Russian Empire.
Russian empire, more
important, more Ukrainians,
will always end up being more important,
but they're these
specificities about Galicia,
which we have to know. Okay.
So this brings us to,
now I'll do it entirely without a segue.
This brings us to the First World War.
Very briefly, what was
the First World War?
This is not one of these questions
where I'm gonna make you answer.
The First World War was
a kind of sorting out
of European empires.
So if you think back
to the earlier lecture
about the four or 500 years of empire
where I was trying to just
establish the basic principles
and realities of European empire.
The First World war was the moment
when basically the countries
which governed the planet,
ruled the planet, decided
to have a terrible war
on the tiny bit of
territory they were from,
kill each other on the scale of millions,
and then tens of millions
and then see what would happen, right?
That's the First World War.
If you think about it, it's like
if you were looking at
the history of earth
or the history of humans
from an alien point of view,
there would admittedly
be many strange moments,
but this moment is one
of the stranger ones.
I mean, you have a handful of countries
who are profiting from
ruling the rest of the world.
Economic growth is
actually doing quite well.
The first globalization
is basically a big success
for the Europeans.
And nevertheless, they
decide to fight each other
and kill each other for four years
with the most modern
weapons they can think of
over trenches, right?
That's the First World War.
So the First World War is a
kind of sorting out of empires
in which, I can't tell the whole story,
but in which by the end,
the maritime empires are winning,
France, Britain, the United States
and the land empires are losing.
And this is despite the fact,
this is despite the fact
that the land empires
weren't all on the same side.
So the Russian empire loses
in the sense that it falls apart in 1917,
the Russian Empire was on the side
of the French and the British.
The Ottoman Empire falls apart,
the German empire falls
apart, the Austrian empire,
the Habsburgs all fall apart.
They are allies, the
Habsburgs, the Germans
and the Ottomans, they
lose, they fall apart.
So, the basic story here
is the story of a kind of
sorting out of empires.
Now, the interesting question here,
just like if you were gonna write an exam,
well, maybe not for this class,
but something to think about is this,
this is what historians ask,
in the 19th century they asked,
"Did the Habsburgs have to fall apart
because of nationalism?" And
basically everybody said yes.
Then a 150 years later,
people ask the same question
and they basically, they say no.
So, it's something to think about, right?
There's good evidence on both sides.
But was the nation state a result
of some kind of long national trajectory
and the First World War
just sort of an occasion?
Or was it rather that entities
like the Habsburg monarchy
could have trundled
along for a while longer,
but the First World War was
such a horrible cataclysm
that it broke them apart
and then nation states
emerged as kind of a default alternative,
which weren't really that interesting
just nobody could think
of anything else. Okay.
So in the Ukrainian question,
I'm gonna be specific
about this for a minute.
The Habsburgs, oh, we can't have this,
we can't do this without
Franz Ferdinand. Okay.
So Franz Ferdinand, he's
in love, he marries,
you know who Franz Ferdinand is,
he's the heir to the throne.
He's the heir to the Habsburg throne.
He's not the monarch, he's
the heir to the throne.
He falls in love.
He's in love with somebody
who's of lower status.
They're in Vienna.
They can't even like walk
together holding hands
because of procession protocol.
She's all the way back
here. It's very awkward.
Not making any yell jokes at
all right now, in the least.
So in order for him to be
together with his wife,
who he loves, he goes to Sarajevo.
In Sarajevo, they can ride
around in a car in public
and sit together in the front
seat, which is very nice.
Everybody loves it,
especially if the car is open.
But if the car is open,
that makes it a lot easier for
the young university students
who happen to be Serbian nationalists
to throw bombs at them.
Which in fact is what happens.
Serbia at this time is making
claims to Bosnia Herzegovina,
which is the last European territory
which Serbia doesn't have that might want.
And as a result, an organization
called The Black Hand,
I know it sounds like I'm
making this all up, but I'm not.
This is how it actually happened.
An organization called the Black Hand
recruits Serbian students inside
Bosnia, so inside Austria,
one of them was a fellow
called Gavrilo Princip.
At the moment when the
procession was riding by
a bomb was thrown, it bounced
off the hood of the car
and it exploded somewhere
else. Other people were hurt.
The couple was fine.
Franz Ferdinand goes to the hospital,
visits the people who are wounded.
Coming back from the
hospital, his driver gets lost
stops to ask for directions.
One of the Serbian national
students is sitting in a cafe
drinking because he's missed his chance
to assassinate Franz Ferdinand.
He looks up, there's Franz
Ferdinand, shoots him dead.
That's how we get the
First World War. Okay?
Just like when you're in political science
and international relations
and they're telling you
about the structures
and like, just remember
that, just remember that,
remember that story.
'Cause that's like the First World War
is the most important thing
that happened in the world
in the 20th century.
And if like Franz Ferdinand
doesn't go to the hospital
to visit the wounded and
the driver doesn't get lost,
probably no First World War. Okay.
So, but the point then, I had a point
and the point is that
the Habsburg monarchy
begins the First World
War by attacking Serbia.
But the very next part of the
First World War is in Galicia
because Russia comes in
on the side of Serbia
and then everyone comes in, right?
Then France comes in with Russia
and Germany comes in
on the side of Austria.
But for our class, what's
important is Russia comes in
on the side of Serbia and
invades right away Galicia,
invades Galicia right
away, September of 1914.
Takes it, treats it as part
of one of the United Russia.
Oh, and they take, Okay, Sheptyts'kyi,
that was my segue.
Sheptyts'kyi along with
the hundreds of other
Greek Catholic priests, gets
exiled deep into Russia.
The Habsburgs then take
Galicia back in May of 1915.
And in 1917, the Habsburgs are
able to go on the offensive
along with their German allies
and take much of what
is now Ukraine. Okay.
How are they able to do that? Lenin, okay?
So there's a reason why this theme,
there are many reasons
why this theme of empire
is so important in this class.
One of them is that you can't understand
the Bolshevik Revolution
or why anybody thought it could happen
without a concept of world empire.
Lenin thought that Marx was right.
You guys know about Karl Marx, right?
I'm sorry, Thank you.
So Lenin thought that Marx was right,
that capitalism had created
this kind of homogenizing monster,
which went around the
world, flattening cultures,
turning social groups into classes,
making everything basically
the same everywhere,
leading to a tension between
workers and property owners.
Lenin thought that was all
correct, but, said Lenin,
and this is a really
interesting move, says Lenin,
"Marx thinks we have to have a revolution
where there are lots of
workers in factories,"
but, says Lenin, "Marx also
says that the whole thing
is one big world system.
So if it's one big world system
and we're revolutionaries,
we are therefore allowed
and indeed required
to push wherever the
capitalists are weakest."
And how do you know where
the capitalists are weakest?
You push and you find out, right?
And applying that logic in 1917,
it was acceptable for
Lenin and his Bolsheviks
to try to overthrow the
existing order in Russia.
Russia at that time,
from the point of view
of the Marxists themselves was backward.
It was a country of peasants and nomads.
There were very few workers.
Marx did not think there would
be a revolution in Russia.
But with this argument, you could say,
well, Russia's part of the world's system,
if it's a weak point, then
we're allowed to push on it.
And then, here comes the
next very important thing,
we'll be like, it's like a powder keg.
We start the revolution and
then the English and the Germans
and all the more advanced comrades
will have their revolutions
and then they'll come and rescue us.
So the people who made
the Russian Revolution
never intended to make
a Russian revolution
they intended to make a world revolution.
They believed that what they were doing
was starting a world revolution.
How does Lenin, okay,
how does this guy Lenin,
I mean, what is?
Lenin is like drinking
coffee in, you know,
he's drinking coffee in Zurich
during the First World War,
which is a perfectly, you know, reason,
well, Zurich's kind of boring,
but it's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do.
What does he, how does he get?
So the German, again
this is not quite as good
as the Franz Ferdinand story,
but it's still worth knowing
when you wanna think about,
like, if someone's telling
you it's all about structures
and things have to be the way
they are and be a realist.
So, Lenin's drinking coffee,
the foreign minister of Germany
is a man called Arthur Zimmerman,
like Zimmerman, Zimmerman.
He convinces the German
emperor, the Kaiser,
that this fellow Lenin can
disrupt the war effort.
And the Germans arrange
for this fellow Lenin
to be transported across
Germany, into the Russian,
into Russia in April of 1917,
famously in a sealed train,
whatever that means.
I don't think the train was
actually physically sealed.
It's just like once you hear
the phrase sealed train,
it sounds cool.
And so it like survives
and the historiography
down to this day.
But that train was not physically sealed.
Like people got off, they got
on, they went to the bathroom,
they bought snacks, you
know, but you get the idea.
They put Lenin on the train,
he didn't get out the train
until they got to Russia.
By this time, the Russian
State had already collapsed.
The Tzar had already abdicated.
There had already been one revolution,
a kind of undefined revolution.
What Lenin succeeded in doing
was turning this revolution,
which had led to a provisional government
into a new form of revolution
in November of 1917.
It's called the October Revolution
because of the different
datings, Julian and Gregorian.
But it actually happened in November,
just like the previous revolution,
which is called the February Revolution
from the western point of
view happened in March.
Lenin made this revolution
because he believed he
was allowed to do so
because of his own ideas
about globalization, right?
Ideas matter quite a lot.
As tactics, it turned out not to be bad,
they did manage to make a revolution.
And in their revolution,
they entered into a larger conversation,
which was going on about
what happens after empire,
in which everybody gave the same answer
and they were all insincere,
but in slightly different ways.
The answer to the question,
what you do after empire?
Is national self-determination, right?
So this is why the imperial
background is so important here,
because then there's this big question of,
okay, empires fall and they break,
and then what do you do next?
Lenin, with Stalin actually,
has been working on this
problem, and he has the answer.
The answer is national self-determination.
"Every nation" says Lenin "has the right
to its own sovereign existence, unless",
it's a pretty big unless,
"unless such aspirations
interfere with the class struggle"
in which case, no. Right?
And this is a very important, you know,
this is a very important solution,
It like, it runs through the
whole Soviet project actually,
that we declaratively, we
accept that nations are real
and we declaratively support them
but we're always gonna be trying
to use those national
energies in ways that suit us.
But if they don't suit us,
i.e. they're not consistent
with the class struggle,
it's the same thing, then
we're allowed to crush them.
We're allowed to starve them,
we're allowed to have terror,
whatever it might be. Okay?
So that's, so Lenin is saying, yeah,
national self-determination,
Poland, Ukraine, Finland,
you know, whatever, it's all fine.
Meanwhile, at the same
time in the United States,
the Americans are also talking about
national self-determination.
When the Americans come
into the First World War,
the ideological cover which is given,
and an argument from principle
had to be made in America
for why there could be a war,
was for national self-determination.
But the American idea of
national self-determination
was basically limited to Poland
and to countries of the Habsburg monarchy.
And it's tactical design
was to break apart
the Habsburg monarchy.
So notoriously,
and it's notorious because the Japanese
actually brought this up later
and made a thing about it,
notoriously, Wilsonian self-determination
did not apply beyond Europe.
But, for the purposes of
this class, you should note
that it also didn't apply
to everywhere in Europe.
So it did not apply to Ukraine.
Nobody was making the argument
for national
self-determination for Ukraine
on the Entente side, but on
the other side they were.
The Germans, meanwhile, right?
So isn't it really, it's
interesting how like
national self-determination,
like it seems like it would be somebody's,
like, it's just Wilson's idea.
Maybe it's just Lenin's idea,
but actually it was everybody's idea.
It was just a question
of how it was applied.
So in 1917, when the Bolshevik Revolution
breaks the Russian Empire and
the Germans then experience
terrific battlefield
success on the eastern front
because the Russian revolution
has just taken place
and they push all the
way deep into Ukraine,
Belarus the Baltics, and
they sign a peace treaty
with the Ukrainian National
Republic in February of 1918,
they do this according to the principle
of national self-determination.
They say, look, no one else
is recognizing you Ukrainians,
but we recognize you because we believe
in national self-determination.
The Bolsheviks are obviously just joking,
the Americans don't care, but
look at us, we recognize you.
But that agreement, the
treaty of Brest-Litovsk,
February, 1918 is contingent
upon something very important,
which is Ukraine delivers
millions and millions
of tons of food stuffs to
Germany immediately. Okay?
So it's a peculiar kind of
national self-determination
where you're not actually
determining, for example,
your own trade policy,
your own economic policy
because the first thing you have to do
is you have to give all of your
food to Germany and Austria.
Now, if we can just get
the timing of the war right
we'll be in business.
This is early 1918, the
Germans and the Austrians
are winning on the eastern front
because of the Russian Revolution.
Meanwhile though, the Americans
have entered the war, 1917,
the Americans are gonna bring,
and this is a formidable number,
a million men to fight in Europe.
The Germans make a last ditch attempt
to defeat the Americans, the British
and the French on the western front
and their idea is they're gonna
do it with Ukrainian food.
That's the idea.
The Ukrainian food is
gonna make this possible.
So they make the effort,
they mount a huge offensive
in late summer of 1918 and they lose
and the First World War comes to an end.
Or, so this is famous, if you
study west European history,
11th hour of the 11th day
of the 11th month of 1918,
the guns fall silent, the war is over.
A new chapter in French
and German history begins,
et cetera.
But if you're studying Eastern Europe,
like the fighting just continues.
It just continues for another
several years after that.
And because you're in this power vacuum,
there's been a revolution
in Russia and there's chaos.
The Germans who had
been dominant are just,
they pull back, right?
And then suddenly what's going to happen?
And what happens, and you have
to read about this in detail
in the reading because it's just too much
for me to get into here.
But what happens here
is that in this chaos,
two Ukrainian states are formed.
Two Ukrainian states are formed.
According to different logics,
which are themselves dependent
upon the different empires.
Within the Russian Empire,
there's something called the
Ukrainian National Council,
which is largely young people,
sometimes very young and
largely educated people,
intellectuals, but the Ukrainian National,
oh, and the Chair of the
Ukrainian National Council,
so the defacto president or head of state
is Mykhailo Hrushevsky.
So the historian, the person who wrote
this kind of social history of Ukraine.
I don't know whether this is true,
but supposedly while he was basically
the president of the country,
he would take his phone off
the hook in the mornings
'cause he needed to do his reading.
Which again, I don't know
if it's true, but it's like,
it's a lovely thought.
Like I kind of wish I, you
know, like wouldn't it be cool?
Like if you were the President,
but no, I actually have
to finish my, you know,
I gotta do my historical work. Okay?
You guys are not as
seduced by this as I am.
So there's Ukrainian National Council,
which as the situation in the
Russian empire radicalizes
itself takes more radical positions
until it finds itself
basically backed into
declaring full national
independence with the so-called
Fourth Universal in early 1918.
Meanwhile, there is also
a different progression
in the Habsburg monarchy,
where the state is functioning
till the, really till the very end.
But the moment the state is over,
Ukrainian soldiers and
Ukrainian bureaucrats
immediately declare the night,
actually right around now,
the last night of October to
the first day of November,
they declare a west
Ukrainian National Republic
with a capital in Lviv, fly the flag,
declare that they exist
and immediately begins
a war with the Poles.
And the Ukrainians do okay
in this war with the Poles
until essentially the
whole Polish army shows up,
or in particular an army of Poles,
I know the First World War, it's a mess,
but an army of Poles who
had been prisoners of war
from the Russian Empire, right?
'Cause most of Poland is
in the Russian Empire.
So Poles who were taken prisoner,
Poles from the Russian empire,
Poles from all over the place.
Poles end up fighting,
so it's a much bigger country, right?
And the Polish army,
when it gets rid of
its other distractions,
is able to concentrate
its force in Galicia.
Where they basically,
you know, so all in all,
Poland out numbers Galicia by a lot.
So the West Ukrainian National Republic
lasts for about half a year.
But the West Ukrainian army
is still the best
Ukrainian army in the field
because the, you know, not
to be too blunt about it,
but because, I will be blunt,
because the left wing, you know,
is basically like PhD
student, sorry, intellectuals
who ran the Ukrainian National Republic,
they were not so big on
administration and the army, right?
There were other reasons
too, but they didn't,
their first priority was
not setting up an army,
it took 'em a while to figure that out.
So when the West Ukrainians
lose and they move east
which is the middle of
1918, sorry, middle of 1919,
they're still the most important
Ukrainian fighting force
in the field.
They find themselves
in this incredibly complicated situation
because in 1918 to 1919
the territory of Ukraine
is being contested by a Ukrainian State
which has gone through
various permutations,
which I'm gonna have
to let you read about,
but which slowly builds up its own army,
its own army is very
confederated and disorganized
and generally run by local warlords,
many of whom carry out terrible,
terrible mass killings of Jews,
that's part of this history as well,
and it's part of the
history that the reading
doesn't do a good job with,
and I'm gonna assign some more reading.
Another contestant is the Red Army,
which invades Ukraine not once, not twice,
but three times before
it finally succeeds.
And then there's another contestant,
which is the so-called White Army,
which means the pro restoration
of Russian Empire Army, right?
And there's the Poles.
So the Whites, the Reds and Ukrainians
fight it out in Ukraine.
And you can see how difficult, I mean,
apart from anything else,
the fact that you're fighting the Red Army
and the White Army
and the Reds and the Whites
are fighting on your territory,
it's a very complicated situation.
And the murders of the Jews
have a great deal to do with that chaos.
But, so by the end of
1918, by the end of 1919,
the Ukrainians have basically lost,
the Reds have basically won,
and then the Poles intervene.
So, and this is just,
that's just an interesting
thing to think about.
Like we're now a hundred years on
and there's another war in Ukraine
and the Poles are not intervening.
Like as a historian, I always think,
I mean like you guys
all think this is normal
because like Poland is just
a normal bourgeois country
and of course they would, but you know,
that's a very recent development.
Like the Poland that exists today,
where the life expectancy
is longer than in America.
And the roads are much, much
better than American roads.
That's only existed
for a few years, right?
So the historical Poland is a much more
east European country,
deeply involved in Belarus,
deeply involved in Ukraine.
But anyway, just the
very last thought here.
In late 1919, the Poles agree to ally
with the remnants of the Ukrainian Army
for one last attempt to take Ukraine,
and they succeed for a while.
In May of 1920, they capture Kyiv,
the Poles then do a very
characteristically Polish thing,
which let's face it, it's kind of cool.
They take their, so
the main avenue in Kyiv
is called Khreshchatyk.
At the end of it is the thing
which is now called Maidan.
So what the Poles did
after they arrived in Kyiv,
was they took all their calvary
and they marched it down
Khreshchatyk, very impressive.
And then they like went
around the block a few blocks,
came back and made a circle.
So it looked like they had just
like these endless, endless,
endless troops invading Ukraine,
which they didn't in fact.
And they were quickly driven
back out by the Bolsheviks.
By August of 1920 the Red Army
was actually in the suburbs of Warsaw,
which was defended by the Polish Army,
but also by the Ukrainians,
which is why if you visit
the Polish military cemetery
in Warsaw there will be
quite a few Ukrainian graves,
which would be otherwise mysterious.
At the end of all that and
now we really are at the end,
at the end of all of that,
it will be Poland and the Soviet Union
which sign a treaty at Riga.
And that treaty will create
a new east west division,
but again, east west division,
where Galicia and another
territory called Volhynia
are gonna be part of Poland
and the rest of what's now Ukraine
is gonna become part of the Soviet Union.
So I've taken you as far as
I can take you this time,
I realize this is hard going.
I appreciate you guys paying attention
and we'll pick up again on Thursday.
Thanks.
(gentle music)